und hinter mir sehen sie den
italienischen vize ministerpräsidenten
matteo salvini
und er trifft sich mit vertreterinnen
und vertretern anderer rechter parteien
in europa mir schon hinein llano die
nachricht heute ist dass wir unsere
politische familie erweitern
wir setzen uns ein für einen neuen
europäischen traum
viele bürger und volker ist die
europäische union heute zu einem
alptraum geworden und nicht zu einem
traum
wir setzen uns dafür ein wo das wieder
arbeit familie oder sicherheit umwelt
und die zukunft unserer jugend im
mittelpunkt stehen
wir machen das zusammen mit bewegungen
die alternativen darstellen zu
denjenigen die in den letzten
jahrzehnten in europa regiert haben die
absprachen zwischen christdemokraten und
sozialdemokraten haben uns in diese
situation geführt
armut unsicherheit herrscht heute unser
bündnis richtet den blick auf die zeit
von heute an wird diese politische
familie sich auch noch auf
zusammenarbeit mit bewegungen mit denen
wir bisher noch nie zusammengearbeitet
haben natürlich gibt es unterschiede
zwischen uns aber wir heben identität
tradition geschichte und sprache
ich persönlich würde den europäischen
traum wieder auf den maastrichter
vertrag zurückführen
da ging es ja um vollbeschäftigung
wirtschaftlich und soziales wohlergehen
respekt vor der identität alles ziele
die von den europäischen bürokratien in
den letzten jahren verraten wo und ich
berufe mich auch auf den europäischen
traum von dem papst johannes paul der
zweite sprach er sagt es gibt
unterschiedliche identitäten kulturen
und nationen und ich denke johannes
party im zweiten kann man sicherlich den
vorwurf machen er sei souverän ist
extremisten nation
all ist oder populist europa macht nur
sinn wenn wir die geschichte und die
identität und die verschiedene kulturen
respektieren eine eu die fußt auf
wirtschaft und wirtschaftlichen
überlegen und finanzen ist kein traum
sondern ein alptraum
und ich freue mich dass heute an diesem
sonnigen vormittag in mailand freunde
aus dänemark deutschland und finnland zu
uns gekommen
heute werden sich uns bis zum 26
mai anschließen wir wollen den wandel in
europa herbeiführen
wir wollen neues blut neue hoffnung und
neue träume schaffen gut wir haben
gemeinsam mit themen die grenzkontrolle
bekämpfung von terrorismus und
extremismus
hier am tisch sitzen keine nostalgiker
extremisten rückwärts gerichtet die
einzigen ostalgie skizziert heute in
brüssel an der macht wir richten den
blick um die zukunft zu natürlich
erinnern wir uns an das was in der
vergangenheit passiert ist
aber diese rege diskussion zwischen
links und rechts rassisten und
kommunisten
das ist nicht das was wir wollen und das
bewegt auch nicht die mehr als 500
millionen bürger europas die diskussion
über die vergangenheit überlassen wir
den historikern und wir schauen nach
vorne ich bedanke mich bei den freunden
die gekommen sind um auf dem leben zu
gehen nämlich europa zu retten
der europäische traum wird erstickt
durch die berührung geraten
die gutmenschen europa jetzt regieren
dieser heutige termin ist der
startschuss für etwas neues und dieser
startschuss lassen sie mich das sagen
kommt nicht aus dem nichts
er ist das resultat sehr viele und sehr
guter gespräche vernünftiger politischer
menschen aus den mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union in den vergangenen
monaten
das inkludiert übrigens auch etliche
ausgezeichnete vertreter von parteien
die heute hier noch nicht anwesend sind
sich uns aber schon bald anschließen
werden
mit matteo salvini von der italienischen
liga mit anderes wissen von der
dänischen volkspartei micro van der vils
partie und mit mir von der alternative
für deutschland sehen sie hier vier
vertreter europäischer parteien vor sich
die heute die initialzündung für die
bildung einer neuen fraktion im
europäischen parlament nach den
europawahlen am 26 mai auf den weg
bringen
diese fraktion wird den schönen namen
europäische allianz der menschen und
nationen oder auf englisch european
alliance of people nations in kürze also
apn tragen
wie erklären heute hier vor ihren augen
die klare absicht der gründung dieser
neuen fraktion direkt nach den wahlen
ende mai in der zusammensetzung des
heutigen podiums war es uns allen
gemeinsam wichtig erstens dieses zeichen
für ein neues politisches projekt nun
auch bereits öffentlich zu machen
zweitens sehen sie an dieser
zusammensetzung das mit den hier
anwesenden parteien vertreter aus allen
drei bisherigen rechtskonservativen
fraktionen im derzeitigen europäischen
parlament zugegen sind
die filmsparte und die tanks dansk
folkeparti gehören der derzeitigen ecr
fraktion im europäischen parlament an
die läger der fraktion und ich als
vertreter der afb bin derzeit mitglied
der fdp-fraktion von dieser
zusammensetzung geht insoweit ganz
bewusst das signal aus dass die
rechtskonservativen patriotischen kräfte
in der union von der festen absicht
getragen sind künftig im europäischen
parlament nicht zersplittert sondern
geeint aufzutreten und zwar nicht zum
selbstzweck sondern um eu politik
endlich kraftvoll ganz anders zu
gestalten als es dort die dort leider
immer noch maßgeblichen kräfte der
derzeitigen mehrheitsfraktionen zum
schaden der menschen europas tag für tag
praktizieren
matteo hat ja schon sehr schön deutlich
gemacht was wir in dieser gruppe anders
machen wollen wir wollen die europäische
union an haupt und gliedern reformieren
aber wir wollen sie nicht zerstören
wir wollen eine durchaus radikale
veränderung dergestalt dass die
europäische union kompetenzen an die
mitgliedstaaten zurück geben soll
wir wollen deutlich mehr macht bei
unseren heimatländern und deutlich
weniger machtkonzentration in der
bürokratie in brüssel und straßburg
wir wollen beispielsweise auch einen
vitalen und kraftvollen schutz der
außengrenzen der union
wir wollen die illegale migration in der
eu hinein auf null reduzieren einreisen
soll künftig nur noch dürfen und können
wer sich außerhalb der grenzen der eu
unsere erlaubnis dafür zuvor eingeholt
hat wenn wir unser europa der vielfalt
der reichen kulturen und seines überaus
reichen erbes erhalten wollen
und ich betone das wollen wir in aller
entschlossenheit dann werden wir eine
festung europa bilden müssen in die wir
nur hinein lassen wem wir hineinzulassen
bereit sind wenn frau merkel und
ihresgleichen den menschen erzählen das
ginge nicht dann sagen wir doch das geht
man muss es nur entschlossen wollen und
diese entschlossenheit dann auch in
politisches handeln umsetzen
matteo salvini und die lega zeigen uns
derzeit exemplarisch wie das geht und
dass man dazu auch bereit sein muss
zurückweisungen an den außengrenzen und
rück bringen die ausgangsorte
durchzusetzen
wenn sich erst einmal herumgesprochen
hat dass es keinen weg der illegalen
einreise in die eu über das meer mehr
gibt dann wird auch niemand mehr auf
dieser durch kriminelle schlepper
unterstützten reise den grausamen tod im
meer sterben
nachgefragt bei meinem kollegen michael
schramm der in italien auch das treffen
heute früh beobachtete michael schramm
matteo salvini von dem eben viel die
rede war dem auch gehört haben ist ja so
eine art programmatischer vordenker für
die rechten in europa oder wie würden
sie es einordnen
diese rolle wächst ihm geradezu zu ist
wahrscheinlich der erfolgreichste
rechtspolitiker europas in diesen tagen
er war vor der letzte italienische wahl
war er chef der lega das war damals eine
3 prozent partei im zuge der letzten
wahl ist diese partei auf 17 prozent
angestiegen und wenn man jetzigen
umfragen glauben schenkt das darf man
weil es sehr viele umfragen gibt die
alle die gleiche richtung deuten würde
er stand heute über 30 prozent bekommen
und es wäre damit der wichtigste der
mächtigste politische man in italien
seine leger ist sozusagen
regierungsfähig und genau das wird zum
ersten mal wohl der fall sein bei diesen
europa waren die jetzt anstehen also er
hat eine bilderbuchkarriere was macht
wachstum machtzuwachs anbetrifft in den
letzten monaten im letzten jahr erlebt
ermöglicht und insofern wächst ihnen
natürlich eine zentrale rolle zu deshalb
innerhalb der europäischen rechten
michael schreiben welche rolle hat dann
im vergleich der deutsche vertreter jörg
merten ist ja auch zu gast ist ja eher
so eine art juniorpartner oder ist auch
ein mächtiger wird er angesehen als
mächtiger spitzenpolitiker der rechten
ist natürlich eher ein juniorpartner
weil eben salvini im besitz der macht es
regierungsmitglied der stellvertretender
ministerpräsident und er hat das
wichtige innenministeriums amt inne
da ist natürlich der vertreter der
erneuten von der afg wirklich ein
juniorpartner die partei ist zahlenmäßig
wesentlich kleiner als es die läger
theoretisch derzeit in italien ist die
afd
und zudem ist natürlich die
regierungsverantwortung weit weg
gleichwohl ich glaube die botschaft soll
einfach heißen wir stellen uns neu auf
wir wollen auch europäische rollen
einnehmen und das ist für salvini
durchaus eine sinnvolle ergänzung seines
machtanspruchs
da trifft ja auch dann die nachricht zu
dass die afg und die läger eine neue
fraktion im europa parlament bilden
wollen so sie denn erfolgreich die
europawahl überstehen und
stimmenzuwächse generieren können
ich wollte euch möchten aufwand zu den
unterschieden minister in europa treffen
gibt vielleicht eine auf einer skala der
rechten positionen wer ist da sozusagen
der echteste wer es eher mitte
links will nicht sagen aber neigt er zur
mitte es fast ein wenig wie die frage
wer wirft den längsten schatten im
kohlenkeller das ist wirklich schwierig
zu sagen salvini hat eine knallharte
politik gegenüber migration gezeigt sagt
er im arm ist sie haben alle diese
geschichten mitbekommen dass
flüchtlingsschiffe das anlegen
verweigert wird das wirklich härteste
wortwahl stattfindet gegenüber migranten
die afd ist etwas moderater in dieser
frage grundsätzlich sind sie alle
rechtsnationale diese parteien und man
muss mal sehen wie das verständnis denn
auf dauer geht so lange man in der
opposition ist kann man natürlich die
souveränität die gegen den gesagt
gegenseitigen respekt vor souveränität
natürlich auch sehr gut betonen aber
angenommen ankäme
regierungsverantwortung wird es
natürlich genau da schwierig werden und
was da eben heute beschlossen wurde in
der bildung dieser neuen fraktion die
nach der europawahl dann zustande kommen
soll ist eben diese betonung des
souveränen das eben zurückgeben von
souveränitätsrechten von brüssel an die
einzelnen länder das klingt zunächst
schön aber bietet natürlich viel
konfliktstoff für den fall dass das
tatsächlich irgendwann realität werden
könnte grundsätzlich sind die parteien
in ihrer rechts abstufung schwer
auseinanderzuhalten
das geht immer um souveränität es geht
immer um ein anti migranten kurs sagt
michael schreibe ich danke ganz herzlich
für diese einschätzungen zum
europawahlkampf der rechten parteien in
italien ein treffen heute in mailand
ganz herzlichen dank